8th of June 2017 do hereby give notice
that the number of votes cast for each
candidate at the election is as follows
Antonius see Tania Welsh Labour severe
Cumbria
die they die mill site can't dive excite
22,000
[Applause]
that is 20 2727 Davis
Byron Welsh Conservative Party candidate
I'm gay says played guide Waddell
cambree Indyk now a meal paid work hunt
up indigoid 19,000 for
[Applause]
Evans Howard William Welsh Liberal
Democrats Democrat I referred all Camry
now can't read again 931 for rock Oh
Ross Gareth you Kip Wales you pick you
Kip Camry queer can't
Edward dig da you 642 Roberts
Harry Flite Camry the party of Wales
email we can't acquit eggnog 1616 win
Stanley Jason pirate party UK in
head were dig now 149 ocurro you draw in
and dat gun board and I hereby declare
that Tanya and Tony Otzi William Heather
has been duly elected
[Applause]
the people of Goa returns at Labour
Member of Parliament thank you so much
or to thank you for putting your trust
in me and giving me this opportunity to
represent you and I promise to you that
with every fiber of my body I will work
tirelessly to give you the
representation that you and your family
deserve I will listen and act I want to
bring the often dusty politics of
Westminster alive involving people in
discussion decision-making and
challenges ideas and the status quo I
want to thank the returning officer and
all those involved in the count this
evening in particular the police their
diligent work is what keeps our
democracy moving on to thank my campaign
team this has been a fantastic effort we
have had in this best six weeks of my
life ever an atom atom Michel the whole
team and the Dower Labour Party have
been absolutely outstanding
[Applause]
I'm looking forward to working alongside
Rebecca Evans they were excellent
Assemblymember to provide that excellent
service usable I'm proud to be Labor I
am proud of what this party has achieved
from founding of the NHS to be in the
architects of devolution and I want to
thank the party and its members were
giving me this opportunity I'm very
pleased at the Green Party has shared a
progressive vision for goer and
graciously did not feel the candidate
[Applause]
they also want to pay tribute to the
other candidates standing in this
election put in your name on the ballot
paper takes real great self belief and
the vision for the country not just go
up we may disagree on many issues but
Byron has served people of this area for
a number of years first as a member of
the National Assembly and for the last
two as our MP yes then so with integrity
and has helped many people along the way
he deserves our thanks for his hard work
and commitment as I stand here proudly
as your newly elected MP our Ewell
promised to fight in Parliament to
ensure goer and the people of Wales have
a country that can be proud of
where the United Kingdom is deeply
divided in 2017 we are a society that
displays a division I never thought
they'd see again in my lifetime be a
brexit wealth our health I want to thank
my wonderful mother and partner brothers
with me what stood by me every step of
the way on this campaign you have been
my rock and a constant in a very
turbulent six weeks I want to help to
create a country that they can be truly
proud of that we can be proud of one
that creates skilled jobs one which
respects and cares for our retired folk
on one which is fairer and more equal
giving young people a chance in life
they deserve so let's get this nation
moving again let's create jobs defend
against inequality and create a society
for the many and not the food thank you
[Applause]
you